avec la pandémie et les mesures de
confinement certaines entreprises
québécoises n'ont pas eu d'autre choix
vous le savez que de mettre la clé sous
la porte
dans le contexte actuel les
entrepreneurs sont soumis à
d'importantes pressions dont seulement
financière mais aussi personnelles alors
comment aider accompagner les
entrepreneurs à surmonter cette période
difficile
le mentor est il une solution c'est ce
que défend la femme d'affaires daniel
henkel qui est membre du réseau mentorat
madame untel
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur bourque un
plaisir et merci de nous recevoir et
toujours un plaisir de vous voir dans
l'âme qu'elle d'abord expliqué nous
qu'est ce qu'on entend par le mentorat
et pourquoi c'est important pour vous
écouter le mentorat tout d'abord et un
partage entre une personne d'expérience
qui est elle même une ou une ou un
entrepreneur d'expérience et qui va donc
partager de façon bénévole c'est son
vécu et souvent on personnalise par
rapport au mentor est donc la différence
est que ces bénévoles
c'est un partage personnel et ça
s'adresse beaucoup à l'humain monsieur
bourque
ça s'adresse à l'entrepreneur parce que
d'abord et avant tout l'entrepreneur est
un être humain et on voit bien vous avez
mentionné au départ la pandémie fait en
sorte que on s'est rendu compte de
l'accélération de la détresse de
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs pour plusieurs
raisons certainement parce que bien sûr
hausse attendait pas ce qui nous est
arrivé
mais aussi est ce qu'on doit faire mais
est-ce qu'on doit pas fermer mes
employés je fais quoi
j'ai passé 15 ans à bâtir une entreprise
est aujourd'hui je dois laisser aller
donc il ya tout ce volet-là
d'accompagnement parce que si l'être
humain n'est pas en forme
l'entreprise ne me sera certainement
vous avez raison puis même on a tendance
à penser ou aux stéréotypes de
l'entrepreneur qui est très confiant qui
est même arrogant que to value de couler
comme sur le dos d'un canard mais avec
les objectifs de performance j'ai la
pression les risques de crédit pelouse
et en plus on rajoute la part de 1000
tout à fait disons que l'image qu'on se
faisait où on se fait encore pour
beaucoup de l'entrepreneur on oublie je
reviens là dessus
que c'est d'abord et avant tout un être
humain comme tout le monde qui a des
responsabilités mais des responsabilités
personnelles et entreprenariale dont
comporte beaucoup qu'il faut pas obliger
oublier non plus qu'on nous a enseigné
il faut être toujours bien avenant il
faut toujours avoir le sourire
il faut dire que tout va bien à la
maison il faut dire que tout va bien
mais au travail il faut dire que tout va
bien aux employés pour montrer que ça
fait voilà alors à un moment donné je
veux dire on peut porter tellement mais
il faut aussi qu'on a des deuils
affaires on a des défis à relever
qui de mieux que d'avoir une personne en
qui on peut avoir confiance qu'on
choisit qui n'est pas là pour nous dire
quoi faire qui est tout simplement là
pour dire tu sais moi aussi ça m'est
arrivé
tu sais c'est normal ce que tu vis tu
sais je suis là pour t'écouter sans
jugement tu sais je peux peut-être td a
enlevé cette brume donc résoudre
mentorat
c'est vraiment 2008 sans manteau réa
dates à travers le québec
c'est quand même 1500 mentor qui donnent
de leur temps en vue cet extraordinaire
et ça permet j'ai des chiffres sont
quand même intéressant on et c'est pour
ça que j'ai interpellerait j'appellerai
à vraiment se connecter vous permettez
je vais regarder parce que c'est
intéressant c'est les entrepreneurs qui
sont en ce moment accompagné par
raisonnement torah disent qu'ils ont
augmenté leur confiance en leur capacité
là c'est quand même un chiffre
intéressant 85% clarifie la saison
l'entrepreneur 1,4 ça oui
et regardez augmente on va parler quand
même de productivité augmente le chiffre
d'affaires de 60 % améliore la pérennité
de l'entreprise de 74%
donc pourquoi se priver c'est quelque
chose qui est disponible et c'est un
rapport humain entre deux humains ou
trois peu importe où 4 mai puis d'une
d'une importance vitale
on part d'importance d'avoir un bon une
bonne relation avec ses banquiers elle
et ses fournisseurs avec son comptable
avec son virage mais le hula mentor se
lâche le gg oui je me demandais je
vendais pas la même quel est ce que ce
sont surtout les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui font appel
à vos services ou parfois est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir des personnes qui ont des
grosses entreprises et également des
grands entrepreneurs
absolument c'est peu importe la taille
peu importe aussi le rang social je le
dis souvent et peu importe ce genre ce
sont des grands petites et moyennes
entreprises qui font appel au marteau
ras de différentes façons quelquefois on
parle du réseau mentor mais quelquefois
vous l'avez certainement déjà entendu
une aux grands leaders québécois on les
entend souvent dire j'ai mon mentor qui
m'accompagne donc déjà eux ont compris a
longtemps qu'il faut quelqu'un pour
juste peut-être nous aider à mieux
évaluer à nous nous c'est les bonnes
questions je vous dis la différence
entre un mentor et un consultant ou un
coach de vie ou un coach c'est très
différent on n'est vraiment pas là pour
dire quoi faire ni rentrer dans vos
chiffres parce qu'on n'est pas là dans
l'entreprise à tous les jours à vos
côtés
mais on est là pour vous aider vous à
être un meilleur entrepreneur mais aussi
surtout un meilleur équilibre entre la
personne et l'entreprise si vous avez
raison il souvent une expression vous la
connaissez mal à main qu'elle ils
vendent très fort au sommet souvent les
entrepreneurs les dirigeants se retrouve
seul au sommet alors vous avez tout à
fait raison de vix est important d'avoir
quelqu'un qui comprend aussi le
cheminement n'entre pas m'appeler défi
oui le comprendre mais ne pas juger
aussi en alternance à pouvoir donner des
solutions
je vais faire un parallèle qui va vous
faire sourire mais en couple on dit
toujours à son mari et je te parles tu
veux pas que tu me donnes les solutions
parce que c'est pas ça que ça mais c'est
vraiment peu ça c'est d'avoir quelqu'un
en qui on a confiance mais qui
al'expérience l'expective et l'humanisme
de ne pas juger d'avoir cette compassion
qui permet à l'entrepreneur de s'ouvrir
c'est pas simple pour un entrepreneur
qui est toute la journée un coup franc
et à multitude de choses de s'ouvrir
aussi aisément
donc je trouve que le mentorat c'est un
moyen qui vient équilibrer tout le côté
financier organisationnel technique en
fin de compte qui le composent une
entreprise donc quand
parle peut-être d'avoir des programmes
d'avoir des ressources ce que je dis
c'est bravo à nos gouvernements
mais surtout n'oubliez pas de continuer
d'encourager tous les organismes parce
que réseau au mentorat passe aussi par
le biais de 53 autres organismes partout
à travers mais oui alors c'est de ne pas
se priver de ça c'est gratuit c'est la
allez-y puis on est là pour ça
nous saluons la merci beaucoup à la main
d'abord été avec nous un plaisir
produire je leur est si bonne soirée
aussi bonne soirée bien voir